So, you've seen some examples of how
API's can work within the same machine.
But what this course is
really going to focus on,
is how API's can enable communication
between several machines.
This is where Web API's
come into the picture.
Simply put, Web API's make it possible
to invoke the execution of code
on another machine via the Internet.
A machine can use multiple web
APIs to create a new application,
sometimes called a Mashup,
providing users with a new experience
that leverages existing applications.
Soon, you'll be making
a Mashup of your own.
But why is all this important?
And what do companies gain by allowing
their content to be accessible via
API's?
By opening up code over the Internet,
API providers are not only helping other
developers who want to use their code,
but are also promoting
their own business.
API's for social media applications, for
example, allow users to share content,
logins, and personalized data
between web applications.
Gaining popularity, and giving users
more functionality with their accounts.
This means more traffic,
and more users for
social media applications
with publicly available APIs.
So, implementing accessible web API's,
isn't only just a nice thing to do,
it's also a lucrative investment for
many companies, and in some cases
a companies proprietary money stream.
An example of a company that depends
heavily on it's API, is Twilio.
A cloud communications company that
allows developers to make, and
receive phone calls, and text
messages using its web server's API.
Twilio has free, and
paid access versions of their API,
forming a key revenue stream for
the company.
Check out Twilio's developer's sight,
and see all the features of their API.